the sr47 sniper rifle slotted together
effortlessly even after so many years of
combat usage the weapon was in pristine
condition in all the time agent Harris
had owned the gun though the thousands
of times she'd fired it not once had it
jammed and that was fortunate because
she had to move quickly in a clearing
about 300 M in front of her were their
targets capable of teleporting in a
split second she needed to be sure that
her team would be a able to finish the
job quickly and efficiently she looked
through the scope slotted onto her rifle
and kicked out the bipod resting it on a
tree stump now she just had to wait for
the signal she looked all around the
marsh trying her best to spot her fellow
agents but they were also well
camouflaged even though she knew the
exact spot where they would be she
couldn't see anyone she'd always wanted
to see the Himalayas it had been on her
bucket list to climb Mount Everest as a
child but the world had changed since
then Mount Everest was gone in fact the
majority of Nepal had vanished replaced
by an enormous Marsh full almost
exclusively of pink Ferns and Droopy
trees that seemed to Sag to one side
unable to support their own weight the
most striking natural wonder on planet
Earth had been replaced by a landscape
that was flat wet and alien agent Harris
curled her finger around the trigger and
took aim through her sights 2 minutes
passed then the gentle whistle of a
Sparrow drifted over to her in the humid
air except of course it couldn't be a
sparrow to the best of her knowledge
sparrows had gone extinct with a snarl
of anger agent Harris squeezed the
trigger she felt the silent sniper rifle
kick her shoulder if they wanted War
they sure as hell would get it the
destruction of the world began in 2078
its designation was SCP orange Das a and
as often happens with these kind of
things no one saw it coming the CP
Foundation having dedicated decades to
researching potential World destroying
events was totally blindsided by what
happened the day the weasel showed up
weasel you ask that's right but before
we explain a question for you is
something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals regardless if you
have a clinical mental health issue like
depression or anxiety or if you're just
a human who lives in this world who is
going through a hard time therapy can
give you tools to approach your life in
a very different way and that's why I'm
excited to tell you about today's
sponsor betterhelp better help's mission
is to make therapy more affordable and
more accessible and this is an important
Mission because finding a therapist can
be really hard especially when you're
limited to the options in your area
better help is a platform that makes
finding a therapist easier because it's
online it's remote and by filling out a
few questions better help can match you
to a professional therapist in as little
as a few days it's easy to sign up and
get matched with a therapist there's a
link in my description it's
betterhelp.com
slcp explained clicking that link helps
support this channel but it also gets
you 10% off your first month of better
help so you can connect with a therapist
and see if it helps you and because
finding a therapist is a little like
dating if you don't really fit with that
therapist which is a common thing with
therapy you can easily switch to a new
therapist at no additional cost without
stressing about insurance who's in your
network or anything like that so if
you're struggling consider online
therapy with better help click the link
in the description or visit better
help.com sccp explained thank you again
betterhelp for supporting this Channel
and now as we were saying about the
weasels a man called Harland stump was
the first human to make contact with the
weasels he was the groundskeeper at site
59 Harin was making his usual weekly
trips around the perimeter of the
courtyard on his right along lawnmower
watching baseball on his phone all the
way when out of nowhere the aliens
appeared just 2 m in front of him a
squadron of 11 weasels materialized the
weasels designated SCP orange DB stand
at a minimum of 3 m tall with 16 legs
and an exoskeleton carpas they share a
resemblance with terrestrial insects
their bodies are segmented composed of a
head primary thorax secondary thorax
tessary thoracic cloy abdomen and tail
with a hard segmented shell covering
their backs and no apparent sensory
organs aside from a radula on their
heads they are an intimidating presence
most striking about them however is the
most delicate part of their appearance
on their backs each weasel has an array
of Flora growing in a kind of garden it
appears that each weasel has a different
array of flowers growing from their
backs understanding the meaning of these
Gardens can be difficult but it appears
the more extravagant it is the higher
ranking the individual weasel is the 11
weasels that appeared before Harland
stump each had a very vibrant Garden
indeed but but no more so than the
weasel held a loft in an ornate Peloquin
Harland stump stopped Mowing and stared
at the aliens for approximately 13
seconds at which point he let out a sigh
pressed play on his baseball game and
continued mowing the lawn he spent too
many years groundskeeping sight 59 to
get spooked by anything as harmless as
giant teleporting insects just three
more weeks and he would be retired until
then he was avoiding nonsense like the
plague except his phone had disappeared
Harland stared down at the empty space
confusion knitting his eyebrows together
before looking up and seeing the handset
in the hands of the alien sitting on its
Regal Throne the smartphone made a loud
screeching noise and then all of a
sudden began to flick between Snippets
of YouTube videos each clip lasting just
a couple of seconds after a moment
harlon realized that the alien was using
the videos to speak to him the words
were being picked out from all these
different videos to stitch together a
sentence barely howly Hy NE barinos this
is foundation reports indicate
Foundation is locally the Masters of the
Universe isn't that right darling
question mark Keen to finish his Mowing
and avoid further nonsense Harlin had to
concede that he should probably talk to
these aliens if only to get his phone
back he told them he liked the Gardens
on their backs why thank you gardening
is kind of our thing well quick question
is your species capable of dying M
Harlen Gul he'd been around long enough
to see where this was going the
conversation was brief Harland kept
glancing at his phone desperately hoping
that these aliens hadn't somehow broken
it and that it hadn't lost his place in
the match until all of a sudden Harland
stump disappeared as did his ride on
lawn mower his smartphone and a patch of
lawn replaced by a roughly 10 m circle
of Antarctic ice and snow no one is
certain yet how the weasels are able to
do it all that is known known is that
they can the phenomenon came to be known
as juxtaposing matter from one location
could be instantaneously switched with
matter from a different location it is
how the weasels first arrived on planet
Earth triggering the event of SCP 001
orange d a orange Das a lasted for Just
2 hours but it changed the course of
humanity Forever on the 29th of April
2078 48.5 2% of the Earth's habitable
surface area dematerialized and
rematerialized half km above the South
Pole cities and towns from all across
planet Earth one by one disappeared and
reappeared in the air above the South
Pole where they promptly fell 500 M
causing backto back seismic events
Washington DC Beijing and London were
targeted first followed by Tokyo Delhi
and then a number of Capital Cities from
Europe This two-hour window resulted in
freak weather events as minus 50°
pockets of air kilometers across replace
the disappearing cities it is disputed
as to who launched the first nuclear
warhead whether it was done by accident
out of fear or as a strategic attack
against a group of weasels orange daset
was simply too chaotic and destructive
for Humanity ever to be able to know
what happened in that short period of
time the result however was a number of
nuclear explosions raging across the
planet before the cities in charge of
launching them were also transported to
the South Pole while the weasels were
capable of experiencing juxtaposition
without any apparent physical harm
terrestrial life forms were less
fortunate during the process of
juxtaposition the bonds between each and
every cell are broken while organic life
does get transported to the new location
it undergos immediate liquefaction not a
single earthborn life form has been
observed surviving a juxtoposition event
in that 2-hour window 6.9 billion people
were killed Humanity had lost this event
triggered the use of project yellow an
emergency evacuation protocol that
occurs at the point where the survival
of the human race seems to be virtually
zero a small band of specially chosen
individuals were evacuated to a pocket
Dimension where they were put into
cryosleep to wait until the Earth was
habitable once again in the days
following the events of orange Das a the
true Invasion began choosing the Sahara
Desert as their arrival point the
weasels started to appear in Legions
millions and millions of them filled the
Desert Sands and went about populating
their new planet but what was their
purpose well fortunately we've been able
to salvage a modest amount of data that
can inform us of why they're here and
what their plans are the weasel that
first appeared to Harland stump just
outside site 59 has been designated SC
SCP orange prime it is believed that
this weasel in particular is their
leader whether Prime is simply the
leader of this Colony or The Wider
species is yet to be confirmed security
cameras were able to capture the
interaction as it took place within s
159's ground in their conversation
orange Prime explains their purpose to
Harland through YouTube clips on his
phone long story short weasels have come
from home world demension for fulfill a
long-standing mutual agreement with
Grandma this is one of many new homes
this is a pretty nice place for weasel
this land is my land from California to
the New York Islands from the Redwood
forest to the Gulf Stream
Waters this land was made for weasles
two Garden two Farm two create Beauty
two spread Good Vibes two cultivate two
remake two terraform etc etc since this
encounter no human has been able to get
close enough to Orange Prime to engage
the weasel in further conversation this
snippet of footage is all that Humanity
has to understand why this alien species
has slaughtered billions of us 4 months
later agent Harris lay flat in the
marshlands firing her sniper rifle at
the weasels gathering in a clearing
ahead of them their operation looked
like Overkill it always did it was of
utmost importance that they strike
quickly and without Mercy sustained
heavy gunfire from all sides combined
with RPG fire and the use of incendiary
weapons made short work of the weasels
all of these weapons were necessary to
pierce the heavy armor that covered
their back
but that was the reason it felt like
Overkill it felt that way because the
weasels never fought back they would not
attack defend themselves help their
fallen allies or even beg for their
lives they would simply stand idly by as
they were gunned down that is until the
incendiary grenades arrived the pink
ferns filling the marshlands caught fire
and began to curl and smoke heavily as
soon as that happened the weasel sprung
into action quickly splashing water onto
the the leaves trying their best to save
the plants the incendiary grenades were
not necessary they did very little
damage to the weasels themselves the
reason the platoon used the grenades was
that it was one way they had found to
distress their Alien Invaders in any way
it was a small Revenge they could take
for the billions of people who had lost
their lives over the prior few months
agent Harris pumped five extra shots
into the corpse of a weasel before
standing down and going to examine her
handiwork they had been hunting orange
Prime rumors had suggested that their
primary target had been lurking in the
Himalayan region but that had obviously
proven to be false among all the bodies
on the ground there was no sign of the
fearless leader frustration boiled in
Harris as she kicked a corpse the thick
shell hurt her foot she must have broken
her toe at that moment a rustling noise
came from the other side of the trees
soon dozens more hundreds more weasles
were walking through the marsh in a
split second her platoon opened fire
Tracer rounds lashed through the trees
and the orange glow of fire danced in
every direction but there were more
weasels many more of them aent Harris
felt her stomach knot as she fired her
rifle into the crowd there were too many
simply too many they were going to run
out of ammo before they had a chance to
shoot down each and every one of them
and she was right the firefight lasted
for 30 minutes before the remaining
Soldier ran out of ammunition dozens of
weasel bodies littered the marsh
floating in the water dozens more weasel
stood encircling the group that's when
the humming started whenever a jux
deposition event occurs it is always
accompanied by the weasel's humming to
themselves it is unclear whether this is
the cause of the ju deposition or simply
a ritual that they perform but every
Soldier has come to know that sound and
each one of them fears it in the pit of
their stomach so they started to
disappear all around her one by one
replaced by puffs of cold air with
snowflakes still gently hanging in the
breeze the human population of planet
Earth dwindled as the weasel population
bloomed large swaths of the planet were
terraformed one by one to make room for
alien Flora the South Pole became a
larger and larger Dumping Ground for all
the detrius that had once been the most
celebrated works of the human race the
Mona Lisa was torn and forgotten buried
under many kilometers of concrete
exposed sewage works and apartment
complexes and the situation only got
worse in October acting against prior
instructions from the foundation the
global ult Coalition launched project
Popco a 200 Megaton nuclear warhead
directly at a large weasel population
Center as the Warhead began its descent
the entire Sky turned a solid dark blue
project Popco immediately fell out of
contact as did all satellites that had
been orbiting the planet the sun moon
and stars could not be seen the entire
sky was just a uniform dark blue in a
desperate attempt to find out what was
going on the foundation launched a Mann
rocket in the direction of poco's most
recent coordinates contact with the
rocket was laun lost after just 9
minutes this is the most recent known
account of events from inside that
rocket all of a sudden just a few
minutes into the flight warning alarm
started going off all over the cockpit
the radar was picking up a solid object
blocking their path gathering around the
readouts the crew came to a very quick
conclusion that the dark blue that had
been filling the sky was actually a
solid object that was encasing the Earth
but rather than abort the mission the
crew decided to persevere having
witnessed so Much Death and destruction
over the previous year they knew they
would much rather go out and crashing a
rocket into a blue wall than join the
billions of humans liquefied in a pile
in Antarctica closing their eyes bracing
for impact the crew Reed themselves for
their now inevitable deaths but it
didn't come instead the rocket was able
to force its way through the dense blue
object falling apart as it went Ground
Control lost contact with the ship
nothing and then a few seconds of audio
the crew had made it they had somehow
managed to pierce their way through the
blue shell that was surrounding their
planet and were out into not space the
Earth the entire planet had been ju
opposed philan B Vu welcome to an
exclusive behind the- scenes look at
heaven now go check out SCP 001 15 files
protected by mimic kill agent and SCP
001 you are the anomaly